de la direction générale de la police à
celle de l'ump on peut dire que notre
invité cette semaine a connu un grand
virage professionnel bonsoir ferry
péchenard bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous pour ce preuve par 3 donc réalisé
avec l' agence france-presse représenter
ce soir par deborah claude avec
également dailymotion cette reconversion
obligé encouragé par nicolas sarkozy
dont vous êtes un proche bien
voulez-vous créé tout à l'heure avec
perrine tarneaud mais on va d'abord
aborder les sujets qui restent bien sûr
je pense au coeur de vos passions même
de votre engagement c'est à dire la
sécurité la police la venue à marseille
de manuel valls a été marquée on l'a vu
par des tirs de kalachnikov
on peut trouver mieux évidemment comme
comme accueil dans la cité sensible de
la castellane mais le premier ministre
il ya vu la démonstration de
l'efficacité des services de police et
également de la gauche est ce que vous
avez la même lecture de ces faits graves
que manuel valls
le moins qu'on puisse dire déjà c'est
qu'il n'a pas eu de chance et bien pour
communiquer sur des bons chiffres sur
des efforts qui ont été faits à
marseille et puis il arrive sur une
scène de western où les policiers sont
en tirer dessus et des coups de feu qui
part d'un petit peu partout votre chance
oui pas de chance c'est vrai c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment pas de chance
parce que marseille c'est un sujet qui
est compliqué c'est un sujet qui dure
depuis plusieurs années et est
finalement je suis pas absolument
certain parce que c'est ça qui est
important c'est qu'est ce qu'on va faire
à marseille et je ne suis pas absolument
certain que la mesure complète était
prise en main annonce encore des
nouveaux renforts évidemment aimé
laisser bien les renforts ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est de quoi on parle la petite
délinquance a baissé à marseille et
finalement ce qu'est ce qui reste et qui
le plus spectaculaire c'est ce son grand
banditisme ou plus exactement ce
banditisme issus des cités qui prospère
sur le trafic de stupéfiants donc vous
avez des cités où il ya du trafic de
stupéfiants et comme les gens ont besoin
les dealers ont besoin d'asseoir leur
territorialité parce que quand vous
vendez du shit bien il faut qu'il y ait
que vous qui vandier sinon vous
n'arrivez pas à gagner suffisamment
d'argent mais ils défendent leur
territoire avec des
des armes des armes lourdes des armes de
guerre services beaucoup de morts démuni
j'ai envie j'ai envie du regard que
désarmé ce qu'il faudrait que certains
élus prône l'intervention de l'armée est
ce que ce serait une solution ou la
solution pour vous non pas du tout pas
du tout la solution elle est alors
d'abord elle est pas uniforme ça serait
trop simple mais fondamentalement vous
avez pas dix mille personnes qui dans
les rues de marseille tir au fusil
d'assaut les uns sur les autres
c'est donc un petit noyau dur de
délinquants qui doivent être traités
comme tels
c'est à dire que ça revient au cameroun
fort parce que les renforts ne sont pas
mis là où ils doivent être
ça ne sert à rien d'avoir des
patrouilles de crs dans ce genre
d'endroit ce qu'il faut c'est améliorer
le dispositif de la police
d'investigation de la police judiciaire
renforcé la police judiciaire renforcé
des moyens techniques de la police
judiciaire ces gens doivent être
identifiés on doit faire l'objet d'une
procédure devait interpeller doivent
aller en prison
voilà on ne peut se débarrasser de ces
caïds que comme ça pouvait multiplier
patrouille
vous pouvez multiplier ce que vous
voulez vous n'arriverez pas à vous en
débarrasser
si vous ne les arrêtait pas ces gens-là
doit finir en prison après que y ait
nécessairement il faut traiter le
terrain le terrain social
le terrain sur l'éducation etc mais la
priorité parce que si on enlève pas ces
caïds des cités et bien derrière on
n'arrivera à rien faire c'est
l'arrestation ces gens-là et
l'arrestation de ces gens-là passe par
le renforcement des moyens de la police
judiciaire d'une investigation très bien
en tous les cas vous donner un
satisfecit au gouvernement actuel
pourrait effectivement avoir su inverser
la tendance à marseille dans un certain
nombre d'affaires on vous l'avait dit la
petite délinquance les agressions les
vols et même les règlements de compte
qui sont en recul tant qu un satisfecit
à l'action menée par jeu difficile à
personne et certainement pas quand le
premier nice se déplace au milieu des
tirs de kalachnikov
franchement franchement pas garde chance
vous avez ya pas de chance n'ya pas non
plus de quoi donner un satisfecit à l'or
et sur le terrorisme est-ce que là
vous êtes prêt à dire qu'effectivement
le gouvernement à apporter la bonne
réponse sécuritaire après les attentats
du mois de janvier
je pense que on perd du temps voilà moi
ce qui m'inquiète
j'ai entendu des déclarations qui
étaient très fortes du premier ministre
du ministre l'intérieur du président de
la république en expliquant qu' on
n'était que des gens avait déclaré la
guerre c'est une formule qui est forte
mais qui est parfaitement exact il ya
des gens dans le monde qui nous ont
déclaré la guerre qui veulent commettre
des attentats eux l'avaient en rentrant
nous en france même dans le monde et en
france naturellement mais vous savez
c'est ça fait maintenant plus de 25 ans
que les djihadistes et terroriste
djihadiste lutte contre l'occident et
contre les français quand j'étais moi le
chef de la section antiterroriste doit
être email en 1990 on travaillait déjà
sur des djihadistes qui partait en
afghanistan qui revenait la grande
différence entre cette époque là et
maintenant c'est le nombre
si vous voulez le les djihadistes qui
partent en afghanistan à prendre et le
kosovo on élira qu'on ait eu lieu et
mène on a eu la tchétchénie c'était une
poignée de personnes s'étaient entre 30
et 50 personnes
donc c'était des terroristes mais qu'on
était capable de suivre et de connaître
parfaitement et de les interpeller
c'est comme ça d'ailleurs qu'on a réussi
en les suivant et en interpellant éviter
tout attentat sur le territoire national
je dis bien sauté international de 96 à
2012 ce qui a changé c'est qu'il ya une
explosion du nombre de djihadistes
notamment à cause de l'irak et de la
syrie et là on se trouve confronté à un
phénomène qui est extrêmement inquiétant
parce que là où il y avait trente
terroristes potentiels aujourd'hui le
ministre le premier ministre dit lui
même il y en a trois mille pas comment
on fait or je constate déjà identifié
beaucoup qui sont surveillés
j'ai su me mettre un agent derrière
chacun de ces indices est pas le sujet
le sujet c'est qu'on passera
malheureusement il faut que chacun
comprenne que ces gens nous ont déclaré
la guerre et qu'ils vont être capables
d'essayer de commettre à nouveau des
attentats d'ailleurs et encore quelques
jours à nice d
des militaires se sont fait attaquer le
type il est attaqué avec un couteau il a
eu un fusil d'assaut vous dirai
peut-être trois morts au site
donc il faut faut pas se poser la
question de savoir si on aura d'autres
attentats mais quand donc il y à une
urgence
il ya une urgence à faire voter un
certain nombre de lois
il s'agit pas d'être dans l'état
d'urgence ou l'état de guerre née dans
une démocratie il faut donc qu'ils des
lois qu'ils soient votées qui permettent
notamment aux services de renseignement
d'être plus efficace vous savez ça par
exemple la lutte contre le terrorisme
sont pas suffisamment aujourd'hui à
cause d'un manque de taille dans la loi
absolument je vous donne un exemple la
lutte contre le terrorisme
c'est d'abord et avant tout du
renseignement une fois que l'acte
terroriste a été commis une fois que la
bomba a explosé au que les gens ont été
tués il ya une phase d' enquête
on l'a vu dans les dernières affaires et
la police judiciaire les groupes
d'intervention qui ont parfaitement fait
leur boulot et jeux et j'en suis
toujours comment dirais-je fier fier des
reconnaissances reconnaissants et fiers
des policiers que j'ai eu l'honneur de
diriger pendant cinq ans à chaque fois
que je voi leur implication leur courage
leur rapidité et leur efficacité
il n'en demeure pas moins que l'idéal
c'est d'agir avant que les uns que les
attentats ne soit et ça c'est le travail
des services de renseignement or il faut
impérativement ce qui nous manque
aujourd'hui une utilisation
c'est d'avoir une loi cadre sur les
services de renseignement qui donne des
pouvoirs aux services de renseignements
avant la phase judiciaire
par définition les services de
renseignement travaille avant la fin
alors des pouvoirs extraordinaires
voulait passer des magistrats c'est pas
une question de se passer des magistrats
c'est pas une question d'ego je suis
passé de contrôle
je crois qu'il faut une loi une loi qui
encadrent l'action des services de
renseignement il ya une phase de
renseignements et une phase judiciaire
les lois les lois aujourd'hui qui ont
été votées depuis les années 80 si ses
suivantes sur le terrorisme et notamment
la répression judiciaire me paraît assez
efficace on a des juges antiterroristes
à parquet en quittant respécialiser des
policiers de police judiciaire question
spécialisés par contre l'encadrement des
services de renseignement est
extrêmement floues aujourd'hui un
service de renseignement ne veut pas
hors cadre judiciaire
baliser une voiture géolocaliser un
portable il s'agit pas de donner
blanc seing aux services de
renseignements il s'agit d'avoir une loi
leur disant vous pouvez faire ça vous ne
pouvez pas faire ça et bien sûr des
contrôles d'accord les actions des six
rencontres en cas d'accord ça s'est
ralenti ces plumes en priorité de faire
ça car une fois de plus le président de
république l'a dit le premier cela dit
nous sommes en guerre
mais je constate que depuis un mois que
les attentats à charlie hebdo ont eu
lieu et bien il se passe alors à propos
de failli perdre du temps mais l'empiré
est ce qu'on n'en a pas perdu est ce
qu'on n'a pas fait des erreurs dans le
passé par exemple vous parlez des
failles dans leur enseignement
actuellement mais ce qu'il y en a pas
une qui remonte à la fusion et vous y
est étroitement associée fabrique
péchenard ah là là c'est là c'était
durant la présidence sarkozy la fusion
d'une partie des rg avec la dst qui a
qui ont fondé donc à des séries et là a
manifestement tous les spécialistes
disent voulait peut-être pouvoir le
confirmer que là on a perdu une partie
de nos capacités d'information et
d'analysé de ce qui se passe là je sais
pas qui sont vos experts mais je peux
vous dire que je suis pas du tout un
accord avec ça au contraire c'était une
nécessité ça faisait d'ailleurs
plusieurs années que c'était une
nécessité et que tout le monde le disait
on avait deux services de renseignement
au sein de la police nationale
la dst d'un côté et les rejet de l'autre
c'est évidemment une source de
concurrence inutile mais il y avait un
maillage du territoire il ya elle est en
retrait de 10 il est certain que vous ne
jurez sans doute pas spécialisés mayall
ce maillage existe toujours c'est le
même la différence est qu'ils étaient
séparés en deux il ya une partie du
maillage territorial qui allait
s'occuper de prem de renseignement au
sein des des séries devenues direction
générale de sécurité intérieure et une
autre qui était rattachée à la sécurité
publique non je crois sérieusement que
cette réforme a été une très bonne chose
et d'ailleurs elle n'a pas été remise en
cause par la suite la direction centrale
du renseignement intérieur a juste été
élevé si je vais revenir au niveau d'une
direction générale de si tu étais un
malheur mais ce qui est fondamental dans
le renseignement c'est qu'il faut que
tout soit au même endroit pour qu'on
puisse analyser les choses
c'est une banalité de le dire mais il
faut le rappeler le 11 septembre les
américains avaient en leur possession
toutes les informations qui leur aurait
permis d'éviter le problème c'est que
cette information ces informations était
morcelée entre les différentes agences
de renseignement qui ne se parlaient pas
d'accord donc il est très important que
pour faire du renseignement
tout soit mis au même endroit soit
collectée par plusieurs canal ça c'est
pas un problème mais soit analysée au
même endroit alors on va parler des
scandales à répétition du 36 du 36 quai
des orfèvres une maison que vous
connaissez bien fabrique péchenard et la
chute de bernard petit qui avait été
nommé il ya un an environ à la tête de
la de 36 vous avez occupé ce poste vous
avez dit que c'est à dire que vous étiez
à ce moment là le gardien du temple on
s'aperçoit que c'est pas du tout le
temple aujourd'hui c'est une pétaudière
non à l'ours pas une pétaudière
j'ai passé 25 ans à la direction de la
police judiciaire à paris
au 36 j'ai été dans une dizaine de
service j'ai été numéro 2 la bri anti
gang j'ai dirigé la brigade criminelle
geagea brigade de répression du
banditisme comme vous l'avez dit j'ai
fini directeur de cette maison
la première chose quand même qu'ils
qu'il faut dire parce que même si il ya
des affaires qui ont secoué pas
récemment on va récemment cette maison
c'est il faut rendre hommage au travail
exceptionnel de plessé policiers depuis
toujours
quel que soit le gouvernement quelle que
soit la la la police judiciaire
parisienne est vraiment en première
ligne dans toutes les affaires
difficiles des trente ou quarante
dernières années de terrorisme
d'affaires économiques et financières de
banditisme d'assassinât en est tous les
jours tous les jours ces policiers
travaillent la nuit ménages pour les
noëls sombre et vous le voyez bien passé
leur emballage
nous avons eu successivement trois
affaires toutes ces trois sont
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que je ne
souhaite pas m'exprimer dessus parce
qu'il ya des infra des informations
judiciaires qui sont en cours s'il ya eu
des erreurs s'il ya eu des fautes qui
sont des fautes individuelles sont pas
des fautes collectives
quand je dis pas individuel c'est un ou
deux ou trois personnes ça remet pas en
cause la totalité des gens qui y
travaillent
ni même l'organisation ni même les
services qui travaillent il ya toujours
des gens qui ont pu potentiellement
dérapé c'est d'ailleurs là si si c'est
vrai qu'ils ont dérapé et si une
information judiciaire et ensuite la
condamnation des tribunaux leur être
rabais doivent être ils ont déjà été
démis de leurs fonctions d'ailleurs donc
bernard petit a été remplacé lui-même il
a veteran il avait remplacé christian
flèche qui lui avait été démissionné
pour avoir à l'époque informées brice
hortefeux
d'une affaire judiciaire et certains se
sont demandé d'ailleurs si l'épisode le
plus récent à cacher un règlement de
comptes sarkozyste c'est faire beaucoup
de je crois que faux-pas faut pas aller
chercher non plus 12h et 14h / christian
flaesch
puisque vous avez parlé je voudrais lui
rendent hommage ça a été mon adjoint il
a été pendant six ans un directeur
exceptionnel où 36 quai des orfèvres
pendant toute cette période d'ailleurs
on peut noter qu'il ya eu beaucoup
beaucoup de travail et aucune ne bavent
unis aucune bévue n'y a aucune bavure et
il a été démissionné comme vous avez dit
non pas pour avoir informé brice
hortefeux mais pour l'avoir prévenu
qu'il allait être convoqué comme témoin
ce qui était juste une façon tout à fait
courtoise de se conduire avec un ancien
ministre lui a valu son poste
ça lui a valu son poste bon il faut que
la 36e retrouve la sérénité oui
absolument et je pense que le futur
directeur si j'en crois ce que dit la
presse qui sera christian simple et
vient de marseille et le directeur de
marseille est de nature à rassurer
apaiser les gens du quai des orfèvres
ça c'est un très bon professionnel alors
on va évoquer maintenant avec vous l'ump
si vous voulez bien et le retour de
nicolas sarkozy qui espérait sans doute
moins d'embûches sur son chemin qui doit
le mener à 2017 deborah claude de l'
agence france-presse
vous vous interrogez sur cette question
avant cela on va voir avec marie brémaud
comment la compétition s'aiguise s'est
aiguisé fortement ces derniers jours en
vue de la primaire évidemment de l'an
prochain choses vues et entendues samedi
au conseil national de l'ump
c'était le rendez vous des grands jours
une foule de journalistes tous les
ténors de l'ump présents pour une
réunion familiale dans la bouche de tous
le rassemblement
mais l'euro rassemblement salle une
interdiction donc de dégainer de tirer
le premier
surtout pas pour celui qui veut
apparaître comme le très rassembleur
mais difficile pour nicolas sarkozy de
ne pas être impulsif la choisissant de
président de l'ump optique est
volontairement d'une partie de sa
liberté bien
il n'a retrouvera le moment venu pour
l'instant son rôle c'est de garantir
l'unité il le fait je crois en prenant
parfois beaucoup sur lui
je trouve ça assez admirable je ne suis
pas toujours capable moi-même de prendre
autant sûrement car derrière l'unité
affichée
les rivalités transparaissent et si
françois fillon ouvre sa veste afin de
montrer qu'il est venu désarmés alain
juppé lui fait une entrée remarquée
malgré les conseils pacifique de ses
amis de l'ump
moi j'ai déjà dit alain juppé laisse le
chez arval abandonne le casque et sois
toi même
sincèrement il est sur le front
républicain tout le monde le sait depuis
toujours il est pour une alliance clair
avec les centristes ou le monde de ses
huit jours et tout le monde le considère
quand même comme un homme d'état
parmi les dirigeants de l'ump sourire
figé de part et d'autre pour les deux
rivaux qui vise déjà la conquête de
l'elysée
messi fait de la salle quand le maire de
bordeaux souhaite un rassemblement avec
les centristes y compris le modem est
plutôt que de faire semblant autant
assumer le duel à venir
c'est le pack unis même qu'il affirme je
veux parler d'un mot qui n'est pas tabou
ici nos concurrence nos concurrents ce
ne sont pas une difficulté et c'est
quand même pas moi qui vais reprocher
aux autres l'ambition
le calendrier fixé laisser passer les
élections départementales et régionales
avant de se lancer dans la bataille des
primaires
le duel n'est fait que commencer
voilà donc vous êtes plongés au coeur
d'une organisation très concurrentiel
c'est comme ça dans la police vos
questions au directeur général de l'ump
oui la concurrence alors la concurrence
n'est pas un gros mot en bien
on vient de l'entendre mais est-ce que
ça fait pas des dégâts la concurrence
parfois je crois que dans un parti
politique par définition il ya des gens
qui veulent arriver et puis prendre le
pouvoir le parti doit être au pouvoir et
puis après il ya un président de la
république
donc il est assez normal que tous et
toutes ces personnalités et de
l'ambition et soit éventuellement en
concurrence pour moi ce que je pense
juste que c'est un peu tôt je crois que
nicolas sarkozy a donné le bon tempo
terre que au moment où il a fait sa
campagne pour être président de l'ump on
y poser la question est ce que qu'est ce
que vous pensez qu est ce que vous ferez
quand vous serez présent de révéler
qu'ils émettraient des pour l'instant je
fais une campagne est une campagne
dirigée vers ce qu'ils veulent c'est à
dire les militants de l'ump
et puis quand je serai élu on verra
chaque chose en son temps
finalement vrai qu'on imagine mal en
même temps nicolas sarkozy devenir
conseiller général de corrèze mais c'est
un petit peu les mêmes qui lui reprocher
pendant des années d'être d'être trop
pressés qui lui reprochent maintenant de
ne pas l'être assez
je crois qu'il a raison quand il veut
séquencer les choses parce qu'il faut
pas tout confondre et ne mettons pas la
charrue avant les boeufs donc il est
devenu président de l'ump il a trouvé
assez c'est pas un scoop ce que j'ai à
vous dire il a trouvé une famille
politique extrêmement divisée ça fait
deux ans et demi qu'il ya des
difficultés des des antagonismes voire
plus voir des dn entre entre les gens et
l'ump tu n'as pas passé loin de
l'explosion
donc ça sa volonté aujourd'hui et qui me
paraît être quelque chose de tout à fait
tout à fait intelligent c'est de
rassembler voilà nathalie kosciusko
morizet et laurent wauquiez en y mettant
pas très très loin des grands postes de
responsabilité il contribue pas aussi à
cette concurrence est à des difficultés
pour le parti je ne pense pas c'est pas
des postes de responsabilité notez que
ce que vous morizet numéro deux du parti
laurent wauquiez numéro 3 je crois que
ça montre que la famille politique de
l'ump veut occuper tout l'espace
politique entre le parti socialiste un
côté le front national de l'autre et
c'est au contraire une façon de dire
voilà dans cette famille politique là on
est pas on est d'accord sur l'essentiel
on n'est pas d'accord naturellement sur
tout mais il faut d'abord qu'on se
rassemble pour créer un nouveau et grand
parti et puis il faut quand même pas
oublier quelque chose on a cette année
en 2015
deux élections majeures on
par en 2016 les départementales et
régionales et puis quelque chose qui est
presque aussi important quand on parle
le nouveau parti c'est quel programme
voilà qu'en mais aussi des questions de
nîmes politique vous savez bien le
centre reproche le choix de laurent
wauquiez pour la région rhône-alpes donc
il ya aussi des divergences elle sur le
front national il exprime des messages
différents
hervé mariton a dit il ya une confusion
des messages larmes partie on n'y
comprend plus rien donc y est
s'il ya une difficulté quand même à être
avoir une cohérence je pense que je
pense qu'il ya une vraie cohérence et on
le verra d'ailleurs au fur et à mesure
des conventions thématiques que quand
vous êtes un parti de cohérent de la
multiplication des positions quand un an
quand vous êtes un parti politique vous
avez comme but évidemment d'être d'être
élu et de préparer l'alternance et
préparer l'alternance ça veut dire
d'abord et avant tout avoir un projet
politique bien aujourd'hui ce projet
politique qui n'existe pas donc il doit
être bâti et c'est exactement ce que
veut nicolas sarkozy donc on doit bâtir
un projet politique
il y aura une conférence thématique la
première sera sur le logement et la
dotera sécurité sur la justice sur la
santé etc donc bâtir un programme qui
soit un programme qui appartiennent à
tous après au sein d'une famille
politique aussi importante que celle de
l'ump
il ya forcément des divergences
d'interprétation des divergences de
stratégie parfois des divergences qui
peut être qu'il veut être un peu plus
important mais ça me paraît tout à fait
normal personne s'étonne qu'au parti
socialiste
aujourd'hui quand je vous suivez le
conseil national ballet des positions
qui sont alors diamétralement opposées
de comment voulez-vous faire coïncider
une position qui pourrait être son
premier ministre et celle de madame
taubira et de benoît hamon sur la
sécurité par exemple entre l'ain qui dit
il faut plus de sécurité et l'autre là
même où le rôle prison leur reprocher
assez bien sûr bien sûr mais nous
n'avons pas ce type de divergence pas à
ce point-là pas à ce poids là et vous
par exemple on a envie de vous
interrogez vous ferez péchenard deborah
cité par exemple laurent wauquiez et
quand vous vous êtes plutôt côté quoi
bobo heineken ou plutôt droitier comme
laurent wauquiez
moi je suis aujourd'hui je suis
directeur général de l'ump c'est que je
suis un permanent et voilà donc je n'ai
pas à prendre le pouls de telus
également je suis gay non il lui avec
nkm je suis également élus ont concédé
par il alors la télé que c'est pas moi
ma ligne politique pour être tout à fait
clair c'est plutôt nicolas sarkozy donc
c'est faire barre c'est ce qu'il a
proposé par exemple mardi au bureau
politique en barrage au fn alors parce
qu'il ya comme il a évolué un peu sur
cette question il n'a pas évolué la
position face au front national était
assez simple c'est d'ailleurs lui qui
l'a initié en 2011 pour les cantonales
de 2011 et le ni-ni c'était nous ne
votons pas nous ne choisissons pas entre
le front national avec qui nous n'avons
rien en commun et le parti socialiste
qui est en train de ruiner la france
donc nous ne voulons pas choisir entre
les deux voilà ça c'était là bas c'est
la position d'ailleurs officielle de
l'ump large
alors après nicolas sarkozy souhaite
faire du parti un lieu de débat donc on
veut débattre sur tout et donner la
parole aux militants dans aujourd'hui
tels que cisco morizet prépare les
nouveaux statuts de la future formation
et dans ses nouveaux statuts y aura plus
de démocratie plus de décentralisation
est une des idées étant que chaque
militant puissent voter sur le site
internet pour donner son avis chaque
adhérent puisse dire voilà on est
d'accord procès on est d'accord pour ça
donc il veut le nicolas sarkozy veut
faire de l'ump et de la future formation
politique
un lieu de débat donc comme il ya quand
même un petit peu évolué comme on voit
bien je sais pas je crois pas que ce
soit ça il a évolué sous la notion de
débat c'est à dire qu' il ait débat tout
le monde n'est pas d'accord
j'entends des voix qui disent ben moi je
ne voterai jamais pour le parti
socialiste et d'autres voix qui au sein
de la famille politique dix mois pour
faire barrage au front national
je veux très pour le parti socialiste
donc les décidé que ray un débat sur ce
sujet au bureau politique
j'étais donc je sais même pas comment
les choses se sont passées le matin si
ou et on est dépité il ré arrivée au
bureau politique avec deux textes
on s'est d'abord mis d'accord sur une
chose et qui était partagé par tout le
monde c'est un quoi qu'il arrive faire
barrage au front national voilà
et à partir de là une fois qu'on a dit
qu'on faisait barrage au front national
il y avait deux positions une position
eh bien on demande aux électeurs de
voter blanc de sectionner et une autre
position qui disait bas qui se
rapprocher un peu plus du front
républicain la possibilité de choisir
voter blanc s'abstenir ou voter le
candidat de la majorité
résumé un des 2 19 il ya eu 1 exactement
il ya eu un débat qui a été tout à fait
intéressante très politique qui a duré
presque deux heures et demie l issue ait
eu un vote
nicolas sarkozy n'a d'ailleurs pas
participé au vote las comme il
présentait les deux motions des deux
textes est un des textes et à emporter
la majorité donc c'est la position de
l'ump
c'est à dire on y vote pour parti
socialiste non vous auriez nationale
qu'est ce que j'aurais voté blanc vous
auriez voter blanc oui est ce que ça
vous inquiète pas vous directeur général
de l'ump de voir qu'aujourd'hui le front
national n'est plus une mais la force
d'alternance bien sûr c'est là ce qui a
fondamentalement changé et ce qui
d'ailleurs explique pourquoi est ce que
nicolas sarkozy a voulu ouvrir ce débat
c'est que on ne veut pas considérer de
la même façon le front national quand il
faisait 5 ou 6% et aujourd'hui où le
fait 30%
donc il faut comprendre pourquoi il fait
30 % et comment faire en sorte qu'on
puisse lutter contre les idées du front
national connaît le front national n'a
pas mes idées ni le parti socialiste on
a on a dit on a un espace politique
assez important entre le front national
et le parti ccm travaux qui capitaliser
sur le mécontentement des français donc
il a fallu quand même
rappelons quand même que sur landreau il
ya eu 14 élections législatives
partielles depuis 2000 12 12 ont été
gagnés par la droite
3par ud9 par l'ump et deux par le parti
socialiste et 0 par le front national
donc il faut aussi relativiser
on aura d'ailleurs un test en grandeur
nature évidemment beaucoup beaucoup plus
important parce que le doubs c'est un
77e de la france figure nationale s'est
pas privé ce week end souligné que des
électeurs ump avait été sans doute
mettre un bulletin front national quand
les sans doute et les électeurs du parti
socialiste s'était en général les votes
n'appartient à personne et chacun se
détermine en fonction de ce qu'il veut
et c'est d'ailleurs bien pour ça s'il ya
des électeurs de l'ump qui votent front
national c'est sûr des gens qu'il faut
absolument récupérer comment vous allez
faire c'est ça la question
je pense que vous leur dites je pense
qu'il faut
apporter une réponse crédible aux
difficultés qu'on a aujourd'hui en
france l'année 2014
si je la prend très rapidement et si je
la balaye ses 190 me les chômeurs de
plus donc augmentation de 20 % des
chômeurs depuis 2012
c'est 2 6% de violences aux personnes de
plus quand vous calculez ça fait
trente-cinq faits de violences aux
personnes de plus que l'année dernière
c'est une croissance nulle c'est moins
de 300 milles logements qui ont été
construits
c'est à dire ça faisait dix sept ans
qu'on n'avait pas eu aussi peu de
logements et c'est l'année 2014 aussi
l'augmentation de 200 milliards de la
dette
ce qu'il a permis d'exploser à plus de
2000 milliards donc c'est vrai que quand
on voit ça eh bien on comprend qu'un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens soient
extrêmement inquiet si vous attaquez la
sécurité s'exalte ici vous ajoutez les
phénomènes de terrorisme qui évidemment
en une tendance à feu faire replier les
gens aient eu une remise en cause de
l'europe
eh bien vous arrivez à un vote c'est un
vote protestataire et qu'elle vote du
front national moi quand je regarde le
programme économique du front national
je suis juste terrorisés
si on parle que de sécurité l'idée de
sortir de l'europe est une idée absurde
en termes de sécurité
l'europe nous a amené énormément
l'europe c'est europol quand j'étais à
brigade des stupéfiants par exemple en
1988 eh bien il n'était pas question
pour les officiers de police la brigade
des stups d'aller en espagne où le
haschich remontait ni d'aller à
amsterdam où l'héroïne arrivé
aujourd'hui
un policier français le partir du sud de
l'espagne pour les honneurs d'amsterdam
peut mettre tous dans sa procédure et si
les gens sont arrêtés en espagne ou aux
pays-bas et bien ils seront sanctionnés
on a le mandat d'arrêt européen et qui
permet on a des échanges les rails
schengen c'est une bonne nouvelle par
exemple on a également quelque chose qui
est extrêmement important ces fichiers
d'empreintes génétiques européen dire
que jusqu'à une date récente si vous
restez sur vos frontières
vous avez un violeur ebit en allemagne
qui
une france qui repart en allemagne est
connu en allemagne n'est pas connue en
france
eh bien on sait pas qui c'est donc
l'europe est un plus en terme de
sécurité
incontestablement provenant là un petit
popote évolué puisque ça fait seulement
deux ans et demi vous faites de la
politique et par rapport à 30 ans de
police donc ça fait pas si longtemps que
ça ça fait un nom à norman g l'a
commencée en décembre de l'année
dernière
ah oui même palancher la campagne
télévisée à briser et de brigitte kuster
il se dirige à deux ans et demi est bien
engagée j'ai été directeur de campagne
de même pas 2 mais voilà alors est ce
moi alors à vous on dirait tout alors
peut-être que mais parce que vous avez
occupé avant était quand même assez
politique alors qu'ils peuvent aller
voter pour le front national je crois
que l'objectif de 500 mille adhérents
pour l'ump avait été envisagé enfin il
est envisagé ça ça paraît extrêmement
ambitieux c'est le même que le parti
socialiste d'ailleurs comment vous allez
faire
aujourd'hui on parle pas comme sur un
socle qui existe on a deux cent mille
adhérents là en 2014 et eu deux cent
mille adhérents à jour de leur
cotisation à ce que les chiffres
augmentent dans ces chiffres augmentent
on est à peu près en ce moment là la
période de janvier je crois et tassez et
tassez faste mais on est à peu près 1000
adhésions nouvelles par jour d'ailleurs
des difficultés à traiter à traiter tout
ça donc si si le flux continu et je
pense qu'avec le le nouveau parti on
réussira à attirer et intéresser des
gens il n'est pas du tout impossible
qu'on soit à 300 milles la fin de
l'année l'objectif de 500 mille et un
objectif à 2017
pourquoi 500 milles vous avez des grands
partis politiques comme par exemple en
espagne où vous avez l'expérience au
moins drôle que nous et ils ont comme
des partis politiques avec 500 600 mille
personnes nous en france on n'a pas ça
donc on est en train de réfléchir avec
le com sur des statues avoir un statut
de sympathisants un statut de membre
adhérent de membres fondateurs et c'est
pour essayer d'attirer le maximum de
gens à la garantie que ça va faire
rembourser de l'argent en caisse
c'étaient les finances de l'ump on n'en
a pas parlé c'est quand même question
cruciale
et c'est un indice au 20 ans c'est une
question qui est extrêmement
préoccupante pour moi bien sûr comme je
suis directeur général de cette maison
bien et je voudrais remercier rendent
hommage au trésorier daniel fasquelle
qui se donne beaucoup de mal mais ça
vous a pas échappé
on se serrait qui le regarde je n'en
sais rien et boulons partout voilà donc
il y avait huit voitures à l'ump ya pas
très longtemps quand je suis arrivé moi
j'ai pris mes photos seront très
récemment en premier au 1er janvier avec
quatre et on en rit encore 2 au 1er juin
voilà donc on fait des économies sur
tout par exemple au conseil national
vous avez présenté bien jusqu'à présent
ont défrayé les gens quand ils venaient
de loin on leur offrait à déjeuner mais
aujourd'hui on a payé aucun des
placements sûrs que tous les membres du
conseil national sont venus en payant
eux mêmes leurs billets de train et ils
ont ce qu'ils ont voulu déjeuner sur
place ont payé 30 euros y compris va que
les membres du bureau politique
voilà parce que ben on est obligé de
faire des vrais efforts pour être dans
le vert c'est les vaches maigres
et oui mais voilà bon en tout les cas
c'est qu'on n'a pas l'impression vous
fais de la politique depuis un an
seulement un musée
si on est surpris alors faire interne au
arrive elle va vous interrogé justement
sur vous avant cela avec le snarr samia
déchire à mener une enquête
évidemment à vous de juger si elle l'a
menée dans les règles de l'art il fait
désormais partie du cercle très
rapprochée de nicolas sarkozy comme lui
frédéric péchenard a grandi dans le
xviie arrondissement parisien
mais les deux hommes ne se rapprochent
qu'en 1993 lors de la prise d'otages
d'une école maternelle à neuilly pêche
comme le surnomment ses collègues est
alors numéro deux de la brigade antigang
maire de neuilly nicolas sarkozy
apprécié son professionnalisme
à son arrivée à l'elysée en 2007 il le
nomme directeur général de la police
nationale
mais en 2012 la gauche arrive au pouvoir
frédéric péchenard est débarqué une
année charnière qui le poussera dans une
autre voie comme son ami d'enfance
amaury de hauteclocque ancien patron du
raid pour quelqu'un qui était un grand
serviteur de l'état de la manière dont
il a été traité
finalement au moment de l'alternance
politique je crois que ça l'a convaincu
deux après tout continuer le combat sous
une forme d'engagement puisqu'il avait
été traité de manière partisane de
pouvoir rejoindre et poursuivre l'action
publique autour de l'action politique
frédéric péchenard qui jurait n'avoir
qu'une seule carte celle de la police
prend celle de l'ump pour suivre son
mentor dans une nouvelle carrière la
politique
en 2013 il rejoint la liste de nathalie
kosciusko morizet candidate à la mairie
de paris
son étiquette d'anciens flics en fait le
monsieur sécurité de l'ump mais
difficile d'en savoir plus sur sa ligne
politique
du point de vue politique c'est
quelqu'un qui est en train de se
construire et on peut pas dire qu'ils se
soient déclarés très très fortement sur
une ligne aujourd'hui c'est quelqu'un
qui apporte son père son son expertise
qui participe aux débats mais mais il a
encore une certaine prudence et lui dans
le xviie il reste discret de quoi
entretenir son image d'homme de l'ombre
de nicolas sarkozy on entend très peu
frédéric péchenard au sein du conseil
d'arrondissement en 17e on l'entend très
peu également au conseil de paris
il s'exprime pas de temps en temps on
l'a entendu en début de mandature pour
porter un voeu sur les questions de
sécurité mais je ne n'ai pas le
sentiment que frédéric péchenard a
après les dossiers locaux en main et
qu'ils s'y plonge aujourd'hui directeur
général de l'ump son retour dans la
police pourrait bien se faire un jour
par la grande porte au ministère de
l'intérieur en cas d'alternance
déjà on prête des ambitions avec
l'acheteur bonsoir père et même saint
michel dont vous avez soufflé une entrée
un peu timide donc dans le monde
politique est normal car ça fait
seulement un an qu'on s'est jeté dans le
grand bain de la politique vous êtes en
train de vous construire dit nathalie
kosciusko morizet ça signifie quoi votre
avis elle vous demande de vous déclarer
je ne sais pas j'ai pas j'ai pas
l'impression d'avoir besoin de me
construire spécifiquement j'ai des idées
ce qu'il ya c'est que comme je suis je
disais tout à l'heure et directeur
général de l'ump
mon boulot ça commence mon travail ça
laisse quand même si c'est bien sûr à
paris je je ne les oublie pas et j'en
suis très content d'ailleurs d'été et le
17e ça ça m'amuse beaucoup ça
m'intéresse beaucoup
finalement on est assez proche des gens
quoi qu'en dise madame le petit ce qui
est sûr ce madame de petty sur le 17ème
on ne la voit qu'au conseil
d'arrondissement donc elle veut pas
savoir ce que j'ai fait le reste du
temps mais c'est vrai que ça ressemble
ça ressemble quand même pas mal à ce
qu'on pourrait faire dans la police
c'est à dire que vous avez des gens qui
évoquent des problèmes et on essaye
d'aider à les résoudre
voilà donc vous avez trouvé des
passerelles finalement en train de vivre
de sa bière bien sûr il ya pas beaucoup
de passerelles la passerelle numéro un
c'est quand même
l'engagement au service du public moi
j'ai été toute ma vie fonctionnaire de
police
je suis en train de payer ce en 1981
j'étais commissaire de police jusqu'en
2012 après j'étais préfet délégué à la
sécurité routière
et puis après j'ai décidé de mettre en
disponibilité de faire de la politique
pour ckoi c'est une ambition la
politique ou c'est finalement à force de
côtoyer les politiques puisque quand on
est chef de la police on en comptera
beaucoup des coûts parce que vous n'avez
plus d'avenir va la police c'est pas
c'est pas vraiment ça c'est il ya deux
raisons
première raison c'est d'abord je crois
qu'il faut remettre les choses en
perspective quand vous êtes policier il
ya des policiers qui votent à droite et
des policiers qui vote à gauche
moi j'ai eu j'ai passé j'ai côtoyé des
centaines des milliers de policiers j'y
suis resté trente ans et j'ai eu
l'honneur de diriger la police pendant 5
les policiers français ils sont
républicains tous moi j'ai servi des
gouvernements de droite et de gauche
entre 1981 et 2012 et je les ai servi
avec la même intensité
je fais de la politique maintenant j'ai
pris ma carte à l'ump en jaune l'année
dernière ce n'était pas le cas avant
voilà les choses pour moi sont très
claires je j'ai toujours rendu hommage
au grand ministre de l'intérieur un des
plus grands musées intérieure qu'on a eu
c'est pierre joxe qu'un job c'est celui
qui a créé sociale à la socialiste
quelle est la police technique et
scientifique en france etc
car ils créent leur aide aussi voilà
donc j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour lui
et je pense qu'avec nicolas sarkozy
était le meilleur
les intérieurs qu'on ait vu dans les 30
dernières années c'est lui qui vous a
emmené vers la politique c'est nicolas
sarkozy alors incontestablement j'ai
beaucoup d'amitié d'affection et de
respect pour nicolas sarkozy
je partage ses idées je trouve qu'il a
un punch une volonté absolument
considérable et honnêtement dans mes
ambitions politiques
il ya d'aider nicolas sarkozy à
redevenir président de la république
ouais vous qui connaissez nicolas
sarkozy depuis si longtemps entre le
nicolas sarkozy qui a été élu en 2007
celui qui a perdu en 2012 celui qui
revient aujourd'hui en 2014 2015
est-ce qu est-ce qui a changé finalement
chez lui lui n'a changé ce qui a changé
la vie le temps qui passe vous fait
changer vous fait réfléchir
il a connu la plus haute marche qu'on
peut avoir en france en tout cas en
politique il a connu des défaites mais
il en avait déjà connu avant des 17 vous
forgez aussi dans les défaites
il a beaucoup réfléchi pendant deux ans
il a beaucoup voyagé et il a beaucoup
regardé et d'après une décision de
revenir et de revenir avec les qualités
qui sont les siennes en étant problement
plus apaisé vous avez déjà réalisé
et l'ensemble de vos ambitions eh bien
vous avez une vue son avenir qui est
forcément plus plus calme plus apaisé
même si fondamentalement vous ne changez
pas mais incontestablement les hommes
politiques quand vous rencontrez un
certain nombre de droite comme de gauche
pas tous mais certains nous disent voilà
mal mon but c'est d'être ministre ou
d'être présent d'un public pas lui il a
coché toutes ces cases là il a plus rien
à prouver à personne
donc il ya forcément une certaine forme
de tranquillité de tranquillité mais en
tout cas son retour ne se passe pas si
bien que prévu il ya même certains
sarkozystes qui sont un peu gagnés par
le doute est ce que vous êtes ce fait
partie de ceux là
non je suis pas du tout est dit par le
doute je trouve au contraire qu'elles
sont
son retour se passe bien il est juste
séquencé c'est à dire que je crois que
face à la situation dans lequel est
aujourd'hui notre pays qu'on voit dans
quel état et l'économie française quand
on voit c'est comme ça comment les
choses se passent bien je pense que les
électeurs qui ont aimé et soutenu que la
sarkozie avait envie qu'il revienne pour
pour bouger voilà c'est à peu près ses
proches monsieur péchenard vous le savez
bien non
sauf que si nous avait annoncé un
tsunami non non c'est pas ça c'est pas
ça c'est un retour programmé sérieux
tels que il a d'abord été élu comment on
a commencé la campagne pour l'élection
dont j'ai entendu à ma façon ridicule
qu'est ce qu'il va faire dans une
élection ça montre aussi qu'il a décidé
de tout reprendre des parts vous disiez
tout à l'heure que je m'exprimais pas
beaucoup et que je faisais mes premiers
pas il faut beaucoup d'humilité pour
nicolas sarkozy qui a été présenté à un
public est ministre pour redevenir au
poste qu'il occupait il ya dix ans à une
période qui était beaucoup plus facile d
humilité j'ai aussi envie parce qu'il
faut avoir envie le seul qui n'ait à
nouveau sur l'arrière cuisine politis
lundi l'onu à londres
rapprochez pamina on n'a pas
l'impression forcément que nicolas
sarkozy a toujours cette envie
l'harmonie beau jeu politique
tous les matchs tous les jours y à l'ump
tous les jours il fait quelque chose
tous les jours y il rencontre les
dizaines et dizaines de personnes il ya
déjà impulsé choses très nouvelles au
sein de l'ump qui était une maison qui
se fanent est qui était en état de mort
clinique
tous les jours par exemple à entre 5
heures et 6 heures il ya un membre de
l'équipe dirigeante qui reçoit les
militants qui veulent venir lui-même y
participent
il était encore hier tous les mois on
reçoit les nouveaux adhérents
donc on a eu mille nouveaux adhérents la
prochaine fois ce sera le 7 mars tous
les jaunes et l'initiative différentes
il se déplace il reçoit déplacement il
n'a pas été sur le terrain pour la
législative partielle dans le doubs
avant le premier tour j'ai pas été avant
le premier tour est-ce que ça c'est fait
on n'a pas pu y aller à part entre les
deux tours vu que nos armées dit avoir
été avant premier tour croit pas il ya
laurent wauquiez va mal dit laurent
wauquiez qui le numéro trois du parti
qui a été lui l'a fait un autre
déplacement à tourcoing
voilà la question se pose est
effectivement de savoir s'il allait
entrer deux tours pour soutenir notre
candidat
malheureusement un candidat ayant été
éliminé au premier tour la question
c'est après ce que vous sentez quand
même une demande un besoin de
renouvellement chez des militants on l'a
vu avec le bon score de bruno le maire
je pense que les gens attendent nicolas
sarkozy voilà ce que peut être un
certain nombre de militants n'ont pas
encore bien compris c'est que avant de
reprendre le pouvoir il faut
reconstruire le parti
quand on est arrivé on a trouvé un parti
en miettes un parti usé par deux ans et
demi de guerre un terme de haine stérile
cuite est tout même forte revient tout
le travail de nicolas sarkozy
aujourd'hui et ça fonctionne c'est de
mettre autour de la table des ennemis à
youtube les gens se reparlent à l'ump
les gens échangent à l'ump les gens ça
si autour de la table vont déjeuner avec
nicolas sarkozy est là et ça énerve pas
mal de proches de l'ancien chef de
l'état
les gens sont en train de revenir
assemblement s'énerve c'est fondamental
c'est fondamental vous ne construisez
pas une famille politique est un grand
parti politique
si vous n'avez pas d'abord rassembler
rassembler les hommes
et rassembler les hommes et les femmes
sur un projet donc un nicolas sarkozy
est en train de rassembler la famille
2 il va construire le projet et après
après seulement il y aura le temps pour
la concurrence pour la primaire et puis
les présidentielles et législatives de
2010 à des scop décédé sida longtemps
c'est dans ces comptes et consensuelle
on a l'impression qu'au contraire ils
stimulent un peu les adversaires de
nicolas sarkozy je pense par exemple
alain juppé bien sûr je jeu il a dit des
choses qui leur donne quand même un peu
d'air il est d'une chose je le répète il
n'a pas d'adversaire au sein de sa
famille politique
voilà il ya des concurrents il ya des
gens dont on sait tous que c'est bien
surtout non il ya des gens qui sont des
gens de qualité qui sont des hommes
d'état la droite française a la chance
d'avoir un certain nombre d'hommes et de
femmes d'état dans ses rangs d'état ça
veut dire des gens qui sont capables
d'exercer les fonctions présidentielles
et ministérielles
rien pas tant que ça vous avez parlé de
la haine la haine au sein de l'ump elle
est aussi donc en partie dirigées chez
certains contre nicolas sarkozy
je pense pas qu'on t'a route est longue
et parler de m oui bien sûr entre un
certain nombre de personnes
est ce qu'il ya au sein de l'ump des
gens qui ont de la haine pour nicolas
sarkozy franchement je ne crois pas que
les gens qui ne l'apprécient pas qu'ils
veulent le combat ne soit pas d'accord
qui préfèrent tel ou tel candidat
moi ça me pose pas problème c'est assez
normal moi je trouve j'ai vécu donc de
très près de l'intérieur puisque j'étais
son directeur de campagne
la campagne pour l'élection franchement
ça s'est très bien passé que ce soit
avec bruno le maire ou le redémarre la
donne n a priori on ne le met un égal à
ça mais on doit le n on pense plutôt à
temps je pense a fini par des cauchemars
les jeunes ça s'est très bien passé
c'est non seulement ya pas eu de n
mais ya pas eu de mot n'a pas eu de
choses définitives moi j'avais des
contacts très réguliers avec les
directeurs de campagne des uns et des
autres et les choses se sont faits de
manière très correcte
voilà notre ambition c'est de faire en
sorte que la primaire se passe de la
même façon dernière question est-ce
qu'il faut que nicolas sarkozy renonce à
cette conférence à l'étranger et je
pense pas est-ce qu'il finira celle
d'abou dabi ifop / cambadélis avait fait
de lui ce qu'il faut que monsieur
cambadélis renonce à son mandat de
député
ça n'a rien à voir alors ça a tout à
voir quand vous êtes président de l'ump
ou premiers ce qu'avait parti socialiste
est pas un métier vous dédiez pas
d'argent bien et que la sarkozie il n'a
pas de revenus il n'est pas élu
donc il est conférencier international
c'est son travail paie c'est un bon
signe genk sa vie le celi temps je
trouve que c'est un excellent signe pour
plusieurs raisons premièrement ça le
prend très peu parce qu'il en fait très
peu donc il est tout le temps mais vous
n'avez pas demandé à monsieur cambadélis
quand il est à l'assemblée c'est en
train de travailler au ps et s'il au ps
pourquoi est ce qui n'est pas à
l'assemblée
bon c'est très peu de temps deuxièmement
ça ne coûte pas un euro aux
contribuables français
rien troisièmement je trouve que c'est
quand même assez assez enrichissant pour
la france d'avoir quelqu'un qui a été
présent la république et qui réclame et
partout dans le monde au moyen orient au
proche orient
aux etats unis en amérique du sud en
asie surtout parce que les gens estiment
qu'il ya quelque chose d'important a
raconté ça signifie donc on a un
personnage public qui est reconnu
mondialement et enfin ça lui permet à
chaque fois qu'il fait des déplacements
il rencontre le premier ministre ou le
président des relais les personnalités
importantes des de ces pays ce qui lui
permet de garder des contacts à
l'international donc moi personnellement
je nous vois sincèrement que des
avantages acquis face à ce qu'il fasse
ses conférences il a trouvé envoie un
mail à sable avocat merci fenart d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir merci perrine la
semaine prochaine jean luc mélenchon
sera l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
et à très vite